now i just explained why bill cosby is
going free because the pennsylvania
supreme court thinks that his fifth
amendment rights were violated but that
doesn't mean that the district attorney
bruce castor
didn't royally screw up the original
deal not to prosecute cosby was to get
him to testify in the civil suit if
cosby wasn't going to be prosecuted he
could wave his fifth amendment rights
and give deposition testimony which is
under oath in the civil suit but the
fifth amendment is different in a civil
context in a criminal trial
you can never be forced to testify but
in a civil trial you can say you're not
going to testify but the judge can take
a negative inference so
if that had happened in the civil suit
the victim's attorney could have tried
to depose cosby he would have taken his
fifth amendment right and then the judge
would say well since you're not going to
testify we're going to take a negative
inference and assume that you
probably did the things that you're
accused of and on top of that it's not
like cosby is going to admit
guilt freed from any chance of criminal
prosecution he put on his defense
in the civil case he tried to prevent it
from being successful so the
pennsylvania supreme court's decision
makes sense but bruce castor's decision
was a bone-headed move that probably
didn't even help the victim that much